wer bei shampoo
jede seite
er weiß schon heute wogen sind immer
wieder alles neu beginnt
die
seriöse leute wir sind hier am
starnberger see wir gehen heute in einem
an die segeln weil der kann das als
einziger von uns umgeben von bonzen
bilden und da hinten ist irgendwo der
kündigung liegt der zweite gestorben
aber das interessiert uns nicht wir
haben spaß auf dem segelschiff ab geht's
ab am ball
teufel ich mein freund ich hab dir so
aufgeht was sie schmeißen wollte
das ist lange her dass ich auf einem
segelboot war
ich habe keine ahnung das funktioniert
eigentlich anders bruder einmal
übernehmen darf gerne übernehmen aber da
muss es auch was die segel sich immer
schön bleiben da ist null und wir
brauchen mehr erwähnt
und jetzt
ja
wir sind richtig stellen
was ist wenn ich jetzt vollziehen würde
dann noch mal denke das würde ja da
müsste man erstens absprechen so ambs du
bist mein vorschoter
du lässt einfach dieses sinnlose das
zeug hält
aber erst gar nicht gut
man denkt gar nicht wir sind hier am
stammwerk erzählt auf mehr mittelmeer
oder madame dick ist
ich liebe leute wir sehen uns bei der
nächsten folge ich hoffe bis dahin bin
ich wieder an land und walken